I've been reading a little bit about
this on Wikipedia make my donation so
basically I wanted to ask you is your
characteristic easy autistic no he's not
autistic no he's not decide well I mean
there is a lot of speculation yeah yeah
no he's not autistic but he does have a
very innocent approach to life yeah this
this very little I can tell you about
the character without making it a
spoiler over your but he's not autistic
for sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well for one he doesn't blink so I have
to do all my scene without drinking
there is a new challenge especially
since I was very glances and it's really
difficult not to blink but hmm answer
the question without without well I
could give all of you today but you know
it one it would be fed you earlier what
I can say is that is probably one of the
toughest roles that I that I have played
in my career
yeah so the challenge is I mean the fact
and I couldn't blink is what other
easier things for me the I think I think
you get into the reality of the
character was was what was the toughest
for me yeah Raju is very very integral
to this film I think that I mean I this
film can be made without me in it but it
can't be made without Raju I think this
is very much him and so he's the force
really behind this film not only as a
writer but also as a director and I
think this is something that's comes
from him it's something that something
important that he wants to say which
he's conveying to the film and he like
his other three films what he's saying
is something extremely dramatic but he
chooses the vehicle of humor to convey
what he's wanting to convey so I mean if
your question is would I have agreed to
the film if it had been someone else who
approached me with the same script yeah
I can't imagine that
I can't kind of twist my head around
that one it's difficult to imagine
someone is coming to me with the script
but hypothetically if some other direct
my move I respected did company with the
script yes I would well there are some I
think the biggest challenge for me was
getting to the head of the character
that was the biggest challenge for me in
terms of physicalities there was
something that we let me worked out and
brought to him one of them is that he
doesn't blink the other design he
doesn't move his hands when he's running
he's like his hands all right next to
him but these are the physical things
which ultimately go in creating the
visual aspect of the character but the
biggest challenge for me was getting
into the head of the character I think
that was probably the biggest challenge
one of the challenges I did face in this
case also was the language because I'm
speaking much good in the film my
character is a voice buh-buh-buh
speaking character so I had to train and
and get the phonetics right of Woodberry
so I have to actually have a expert in
Bhojpuri sit with me read out each line
and I would write it fir entity so I
memorized all the lines phonetically
first and you know I took me three to
four months to make the lines my own and
to own them
[Music]
surely study harder and in World War I
I wish that was possible for me to do
but no that's that's not true
I think I mean once I'm offset then I'd
try to be myself I think I think to be
very honest with for me the when I'm on
camera when I'm on set I really I like
to be in the state of semi-consciousness
where I'm conscious enough to remember
instructions but I'm lost enough to be
the character and be in the moment and
often even that is difficult to achieve
so so in all honesty if I achieve
becoming the character even just for the
moment of the short that's a big
achievement in itself
[Music]
well PK is his name his initials that's
what that's what he's called he's now
producing tones in Hollywood as well he
made a move and he said he doesn't know
how much did that for him to achieve
good morning he doesn't know about the
next challenges do you know what
colleges are there
well I think actually for me the I'm not
someone who's really thinking out of
Indian cinema I think that we have such
a large and healthy audience who are own
and I have a very deep and emotional
connect with that audience and I think
there are innumerable possibilities of
what stories we can tell to one audience
in India I think that's that's in one
lifetime you can't even tell I don't
know one hundredth of all the material
that is possibly there 1,000 it's
infinite for me so uh so I I feel
there's a lot to do here I feel there's
a lot for that you see the film I'm
afraid I can't tell you the second part
of the film you know this particular
film is is especially challenging for us
to talk about because while we talk
about it I think we don't want to spoil
I mean I would like the experience that
that you have of the film to be similar
to mind when I read the script for the
first time or when Raju narrated to me
for the first time because I was totally
blank towards what he was going to
narrate to me and and the experience of
that journey is is quite beautiful so I
don't want to spoil that you know by
telling you what it's about
[Music]
mm most many concerts too much about the
movie but why is this character so
special
why is the story of the book so special
to you that maybe people is wrong about
us when I think it's a story that
touched me it moved me it made me cry it
made me laugh
it made me ask questions to myself and
and it is very emotional experience
actually for reading the script or going
through the script and I hope that all
of that has come into the film and the
character of PK is actually I don't
think Raju and reach out to both the
writers I don't think they intended in
that way I don't think they planned it
that way but it is somehow very
japonesque as a character when I see him
so yeah that's about what I can say
since the count was killed by us by your
character I wanted to know is that
seeing you and the transistors
[Music]
no that's very much part of the film in
fact all the stills that you see are
used in a post to promotion are all
moments from the film so for example
this moment of him is police in the form
of in this all of this is actually these
are shots which would take an on-set so
these are all moments in the film and
and that particular moment which is the
first poster with me with the transistor
is one of the important moments that is
if owns the key art really of of the
film in that one image captures you know
what the film was the plot of the film
is yeah and sorry from that yeah when
you surprised by the kind of reaction
some people had for your picture well
not really I mean I think that there was
a lot of there was a lot of strong
reaction towards that a lot of people
loved it a lot of people were
scandalized by it and I think it's very
understandable to receive that kind of
reaction but we had to be honest with
you know towards the film and and that
that that image really captures the in
essence the key art of the film so
irrespective of what the response was
going to be you would have to go with
that as a key art can that is also in
relation to that hasn't been a problem
no it's not being a problem we have
already received a sense of
certification and that seems very much
in the film
[Music]
and we say interesting story well you
know BK has been a really amazing
experience for me I have to say not only
working once again with Raju and with AB
echad
but also working with Anushka and
Baumann would have been really wonderful
Sanju was amazing to work with he's such
a warm he brings such walk to the set
and and to the film when you know when
his character appears in the film he is
got an amazing energy about him he's got
this strange mix between someone who
appears extremely strong and at the same
time very very vulnerable and and I grew
really fond of him and one thing that
actually happened to me for the first
time in my life is that but number of
times when I was filming for this film
what Raju and I had planned for me to do
with the scene or in the shot and in the
rehearsals once the camera was rolling
in Raju would say action and I would
start performing suddenly I would find
that actually I'm not doing what what we
had rehearsed to what we had planned and
I found that I was hitting different
notes in different keys which I had not
planned and I don't know how that
happened but that happened repeatedly on
this film I don't know I have no idea up
till now till today what hey or how that
happened but when that did you know what
not you and I really like what what
happened and I don't have an answer as
to how that oh boy that have forgiven
today just out of curiosity I mean just
to give us an idea about what rating is
gonna get here most everything is about
what certificate as it go in
thank you in you a it's you a in India
so I would imagine in the UK it would
the similar rating would be 20 is that
what we're building that's what I'm
hoping
[Music]
[Music]
yeah guys really over is a really
wonderful co-star she's totally you know
focused on her work she has a lot of you
know and really wonderful energy about
her and she's a big co-star to work with
I really well you know I mean after all
these years I still get nervous I don't
know how to get rid of that so I really
don't know how to cope with the pressure
I just have sleepless nights before the
release of the film and I just worry
about whether you know whether people
would react to the film the way that I
did when I you know about the script for
the first time so that's something that
always keeps coming back to me right up
to the day of the release so so I'm not
there's no way I can cope with the
pressure relief any better but I don't
let that bother me when I'm working on
the film I don't let that bother me when
I'm selecting a film when I'm selecting
a film I you know I'd like to react
instinctively to it the moment when the
ratio gets over or I finished reading a
script what am I feeling in that one of
time am I really excited by what I've
read it doesn't touch me does it move me
and if it does then I want to do it if
it's something that I love I want
so then when I'm working on it I'm you
know in the process of making it it's
only after when the work is complete
that I start worrying yeah I think the
film is shaped up pretty much how he
would have liked it to so I think the
vision that he had I think yeah a number
of things actually have been ideal in
which there were a number of scenes that
I would have you know really hesitated
in doing I want to be comfortable doing
them one of them being the song that we
actually showed on that particular show
that you mentioned in completely
security here 20 years so you know a
woman is constantly being compared to an
object literally so you know there have
been a number of films that I've done
which today when I look back I regret
having having done that you know
sometimes I don't think a lot of us
don't really mean mean mean to do what
we end up doing it's I think a lack of
sensitivity that we have towards these
issues and I think it's important for us
to sensitize ourselves not only towards
women's issues but also how we portray
children perhaps ignorance and and many
other things if you know I'll give an
example
I produced a film called Johnny to your
Jelena and which is a romantic comedy
and there was a branch first filled and
there's a scene in that film where he
where they are at a club and these two
guys who are extremely male and macho
walk into the club well actually the
rider to the club on horses it is played
by an baz and so here they meant to be
this really macho guys who come in the
air and they're dancing on the floor and
they start you know acting flesh of the
girl starts flirting with her she gets
uncomfortable he Bravo toises this and
decides to try and help her so he tells
his friends to wait outside and he keep
the car ready and then he goes and then
does his play acting as if he knows the
girl and his lover or ex lover or
something and he says you know you
didn't tell me that you had AIDS and
accuses her well then back off when they
hear that and it was meant to be a funny
scene which people saw liked in the film
was a success three months after the
film released I received a letter from a
girl who said that you know I've watched
your friends I really liked your work
and I really respect the work that you
do but I want to tell you something that
really hurt me and she mentioned this
scene through this film and she said
that my sister has AIDS and you're the
meeting that you depicted a person who
has AIDS or shown to be a person who
people have to shun or run away from or
you know or something that really hurt
me that's when I realize that you know I
should I really shouldn't have done that
and I should have be much more sensitive
and I wrote back I apologized to her
that you know it's something that I
regret and is something that I really
should have done it didn't occur to me
so there are many times that we end up
doing things that creative people as
creative people and if you know me
sometimes you don't realize what what we
are conveying you know sometimes you
think it's funny individually but later
on we sometimes realize that maybe this
should have been shown in this light
creating something else which is funny
you know where the where the character
saves the girl or helps the girl out of
that situation
this needn't have been the route that we
selected so I think it would be nice if
I think at this point in time I think
it's time that the creative people in
Indian cinema should kind of stop and
pause and reflect on on a number of
these kind of issues how are we
reflecting women how are we showing you
know children
conveying various things yes no I think
it was a gradual process I think as as I
even mature as a person as I matured
even as a creative person
in how I'm communicating in what I'm
communicating so they were at different
times of you know hopefully over time
had become more and more sensitive about
different issues at this point of time I
haven't taken on any films I'm leading
scripts to see which one I would like to
work on next so at this point of time I
haven't signed any film so next year my
team and I are also taking a break I
mean I'm talking about the sentiment of
the team we've been working for the last
five years on the show so we're taking a
bit of a break from SMG so next year I
won't be doing a film but I don't know
which film yet have you decided
[Music]
because it is saying that a new road PA
is no fast movements favorites their
life enacting clear and what what makes
it so special and we were told has
embarking quiet what seems to be quite
eccentric character and be worried over
how we wear it I think I think I found
it to be one of our most challenging
roles because of the way because of the
way the character is because of who the
character is that was for me the
toughest challenge and when you see the
film you you will realize what I mean
was I apprehensive you know I think I am
pretty much apprehensive about every
character that I approach before I start
working on it because until I give my
first shot I'm still you know battling
struggling to hit the right note and to
grab the you know the character by the
garden so that process goes on until I
give my first shot you know and it's a
process where I am always doubting
wondering is it right or not and then I
you know what I'm actually shooting it
that's when I feel whether I've gotten
aha
it's kind of a nebulous process
[Music]
with image was the look okay well so
some things about the look one of them
is that so I did describe it physically
I have green eyes where one lenses he
doesn't blink so that's one of his
physical characteristics my ears stick
out in the film I mean this did not in
real life
also but in the film we kind of use that
to our advantage and really make them
pop out and so I don't write because you
know how long it took us I even the
clothes that I wear in the film none of
the clothes were made for me they were
all clothes the costume designers picked
off people on the streets so when they
like something the request is the person
to you know give them the shower pant or
t-shirt or whatever it may be and shoes
or jumpers and you know hopefully that
person would agree to that so all the
clothes and stuff stuff that we picked
off the streets from people who've been
wearing this so this entire process of
writing and how what the character is
would have taken us at all
six months or so